renseignement britannique je suis ici
avec l'approbation de votre département
d'État on m'a envoyé vous demander
d'aller au Mexique récupérer un
prisonnier
nous pensons qu'il prépare un attentat à
Londres
c'est dommage ranger j'aurais bien aimé
mesurer à vous
vous saviez qu'il l'entraide le
récupérer McBride
vous êtes au Royaume-Uni à présent la
procédure c'est ce qui doit tout dicter
est-ce que vous convenez avoir fait
preuve d'inconscience
il y a deux types de participants à ce
jeu là
ceux qui sont en cavale
et ceux qui les chassent
on a capté leur attention
la chance sourit aux audacieux
montre-moi tes mains
bonne chance